today on the Matt Walsh Show sex ed
curricula in public schools now includes
lessons on porn literacy we'll have to
talk about that unfortunately also
Lindsey Graham proposes a federal
abortion ban right before the midterms
I'll tell you why as a die-hard
pro-lifer myself I do not support this
move plus Dr Phil takes on the abortion
issue also uh Jimmy Kimmel is finally
accused of racism but not because of all
the blackface he's done in the past and
in our daily cancellation we have our
most creative attempt yet to solve the
what is a woman riddle all of that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
Progressive is a totalitarian screaming
to get out and the team at the front
page magazine has been unmasking these
totalitarians since the earliest days of
the internet founded by David Horowitz a
former red diaper baby and a new leftist
who ultimately became an enemy of the
last and a best-selling author front
page magazine has spent over two decades
combating the radical left's efforts to
destroy America there are two new
podcasts which are called the right take
with Mark Thompson and the Jason Hill
show offer riveting interviews and
insightful coverage of politics culture
and current events the right take with
Mark tapson offers fascinating in-depth
cultural commentary as well as
interviews with well-known conservative
thinkers the Jason Hill show offers
thoughtful deep Dives about the
ideologies of the radical left and
interviews with renowned intellectuals
like Peter wood and Bruce Gilley it
takes a village to combat the radical
left's efforts to destroy America that's
why you as a fan of my show should check
out all of these guys over at front page
magazine by visiting
frontpagemag.com and while you're there
support are caused by making a tax
deductible donation inside every
Progressive is a totalitarian screaming
to get out and know and no one
understands that better than the team at
front page magazine so go check out
frontpagemag.com today
well it's not always easy to live in a
decaying Society watching civilization
fall to pieces around you can really
take a toll on your mental health I
think and so it's understandable that
we're sometimes inclined to tell
ourselves comforting lies you know we
want to take solace and pleasant
encouraging myths and superstitions and
one such fiction is that um we like to
tell ourselves is that we can escape our
cultural Decay by just moving away from
it physically we like to pretend that
most of the really crazy and disturbing
stuff happening in our country can be
avoided by simply living somewhere that
isn't San Francisco or Seattle or Austin
Texas or anywhere in Vermont
but that's not the case because the
media the internet federal government
the education system they act as a
delivery service for all manner of
perversion and moral insanity and
they're everywhere you can't completely
Escape it no matter where you go you
cannot socially distance yourself away
from this contagion unless you you're
moving uh all the way into like the
unexplored regions of the Amazon or
somewhere like that it is um still
certainly a good idea to stay away from
the most demented leftist hellholes it's
possible to find places in America that
are much better and safer than that well
they never they'll never be completely
safe and that's an important thing to
realize
so that we um don't let our guard down
completely for example Idaho
is about as red as a red State can get
politically it's voted for the
Republican candidate in every
presidential election since forever I
mean at least for the past 40 years and
longer and yet as Libs of tick tock
reports today the Idaho Department of
Health and Welfare is teaming up with an
activist group to provide porn literacy
materials for children in school the
Idaho Freedom Foundation organization
has more details about this quote
Idaho's Department of Health and Welfare
implements a sex education curriculum
endorsed by Planned Parenthood in its
schools the curriculum and training for
sex education facilitators is purchased
from an interest group that promotes
queering education and normalizing the
consumption of pornography Idaho law
requires sex education taught in public
schools to reinforce traditional family
Arrangements idhw promotes what Idaho
law prohibits however idhw takes funds
from federal programs like the personal
responsibility education program and
title V sexual risk avoidance education
then idhw acquired sex education
products from non-profits like education
training and research organization which
which is ETR whose curriculum is
developed and endorsed by Planned
Parenthood
yes Planned Parenthood has taken a
special interest in sex education not
just in Idaho in Idaho but across the
country for a long time it's not
difficult to see why sexualizing kids at
younger and younger ages means more and
more customers for them in the long run
the earlier that they sexualize kids
than the more Reckless sexual behavior
you can expect and then the more quote
unquote unwanted pregnancies the more
STDs and then you get the more people
walking into Planned Parenthood clinics
so it's from a business perspective
makes a lot of sense for them
here's a little more from the report it
says ETR is reducing the risk curriculum
uh promises to teach abstinence but
instead ETR delivers a variety of
approaches including an lgbtq inclusive
curriculum that queers education with an
emphasis on gender identity sexual
orientation and behavior
ETR also advocates for teaching
elementary students about porn literacy
which involves instruction on Kink and
power pleasure sexual identity sexual
acts and sexual exploration in relation
to pornography
now if you'd like to know more about
porn literacy or even if you don't
either way here's a video from ETR
explaining watch
we can promote a shame free educational
Space by letting young people know that
it's okay if they are curious It's okay
if they have watched porn and it's okay
if they have thought about porn I always
make sure to say someone being curious
about sex and or porn does not make them
a bad person it makes them human it's so
important we normalize that this is a
natural human experience and I also want
to point uh make a point to share that
not wanting to watch porn is also
completely fine there's no judgment in
shame for not being curious that's okay
too and we want to create environments
in the classroom where students don't
shame each other
so as an educator my job is to provide
information about sexual health and have
students critically think by exploring
all sides of an issue critical thinking
skills are the largest component of porn
literacy it's the ability for young
people to analyze and ask questions
about the media that they're viewing
critical thinking skills allow young
people to understand the intention
behind pornography so much of sex
education is reflecting on our values
and beliefs in relation to a topic and
porn literacy is no exception for
facilitators it's first important for
them to reflect on their reasons for
wanting to teach foreign literacy do
they want to teach porn literacy because
they believe watching porn and by
extension sex work is inherently bad and
they want to stop young people from
accessing it that's unfortunately not
going to lead to good conversations
because it's pushing one agenda that
porn is bad
no we uh we wouldn't want to give the
kids a negative view of hardcore porn
you know we don't want to bias
nine-year-olds against pornography
before they've even had a chance to
check out PornHub for themselves we
wouldn't want to do that
the real goal they say is to teach
critical thinking skills to the porn
viewer
yes because pornography is famous for
its ability to nurture critical thinking
skills everyone knows that the average
porn viewer is only watching it so that
he can hone his skills of discernment
which is quite a euphemism
now however if we leave the Land of
Make-Believe and we come back to
realityville which is where I prefer to
live we can plainly see that the
opposite is the case porn actually
destroys critical thinking this is why
porn viewers become less Discerning the
more they watch
porn manipulates the brain it floods its
reward systems with dopamine and creates
an effect similar to a drug
research has shown that over time this
process results in increasingly dire
physical changes to the brain itself I
mean porn changes your brain physically
you can see it on a brain scan it warps
it and rewires it porn has an especially
corrosive effect on the prefrontal
cortex which is precisely the part of
the brain most involved in critical
thinking and discernment
as an article in neurosciencenews.com
says porn use has been correlated with
erosion of the prefrontal cortex the
region of the brain that houses
executive functions like morality
willpower and impulse control to better
understand the role of this structure in
Behavior it's important to know that it
remains under development underdeveloped
during childhood this is why children
struggle to regulate their emotions and
impulses damage to the prefrontal cortex
and adulthood is termed hypofrontality
which predisposes an individual to
behave compulsively and make poor
decisions
does that remind you of anyone
like everyone does it remind you of
everyone you know if it seems like
people these days are are stuck in
Perpetual adolescence their maturation
stunted lingering in a kind of juvenile
State forever
that's not your imagination that is in
fact what's happening and rampant porn
use in childhood has much to do with
this problem it's not the only culprit
it's not the only thing causing a
problem but it's definitely contributing
to it
kids are being exposed to material that
corrodes the very parts of their brain
necessary for attaining intellectual
maturity
if we want children to learn critical
thinking the very last thing we should
ever do is introduce them to pornography
of course there are many other reasons
to refrain from intentionally exposing
them to sexual content uh reasons both
scientific and moral not to mention
legal
it's against the law to do exactly what
this Idaho sex ed program has declared
its intention to do and what so many
other sex ed programs across the country
do every single day
now the fact that this sort of insanity
is happening in a sex ed program in
Idaho
only goes to show once again
that sex education is hopelessly uh
flawed as a concept there is no rescuing
it
there is no good version of sex ed all
sex ed traces back to Alfred Kinsey and
is structured on his theories of human
sexuality even abstinence only sex ed is
absurd because it is abstinence
education fundamentally built on the
work of a degenerate pedophile
none of these conversations have any
place in the school system and no matter
what you do
no matter what sort of sex ed program
you devise it will always devolve into
this sort of thing always every time
porn literacy and all the other
varieties of perversion that's always
what it turns into and that's because
this is what sex said was always meant
to be and to achieve
this is its natural and intended
endpoint
Alfred Kinsey looking up from Hell while
roasting in the Flames probably takes at
least a little bit of pleasure amid his
eternal damnation in the fact that sex
that has turned into exactly what he
wanted it to be
he's looking up from hell at sex ed and
porn literacy and saying yes exactly see
that's what I wanted
and that's why he's where he is right
now
we might also ask
why there would be such an insistence on
exposing kids to porn I mean it's not
like anyone needs help finding it we
already live in a porn addicted Society
everyone is familiar you know with porn
certainly and everyone is familiar with
the Staggering numbers that places like
PornHub boast you know at the end of
each year the many billions of
Collective hours Americans spend
watching porn uh the many and
increasingly disgusting varieties and
genres they explore and so on
and we're all familiar with that
and it's not just PornHub enjoying the
windfall
the CEO of only fans Who We Know by the
way almost nothing about
okay we know his name we don't know
anything else about this guy he escapes
media scrutiny despite being the most
prolific pimp in the history of the
world perhaps second only to Hugh Hefner
but he has earned 500 million dollars
just over the past two years half a
billion in his pocket from only fans
suffice to say that people are watching
lots and lots of porn
already
so why do activists and school teachers
but I repeat myself want to get even
more people sucked into this world
because
here's the answer when a person is
addicted to porn
they are exactly where our culture wants
them to be
and how it wants them to be
so as already established porn tends to
erode your critical thinking skills your
powers of discernment and self-control
that is all advantageous to the left I
mean they love that
porn isolates people makes them lonely
emotionally and spiritually desolate and
desperate
porn also obviously militates against
all of the Traditional Values which we
used to call virtues Chastity Temperance
patience humility
all dwindle away through porn
consumption
so
isolated
undiscerning lacking in self-control
lacking in critical thinking lonely and
temperate unchaste
that's how the left wants us
because for one thing it makes us easier
to control
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
um first of all look I'm not going to
make a big thing of it I've already
talked
about this uh I think we reposted my
rant on this subject on YouTube over the
weekend so I'm not going to be labored
I'm not going to spend but I I just need
to say I have to say
all I'm going to say is that yesterday I
was driving home from work
I was on Back Country Roads and I found
myself stuck in traffic which is unusual
because there's not a lot of you know
it's it's it's usually not a lot of
traffic there and I'm and I'm moving out
of snail's pace and I'm stuck there for
you know several minutes and I'm
thinking what's going on I thought there
was an accident
and then uh we I get to the the source
of the problem only to find out that
it's a gang of dorks on bicycles in the
middle of the damn street
holding up the lines of cars behind them
and forcing everyone to go around them
across a double yellow line on a windy
Country Road into oncoming traffic
so
they for the sake of their Recreation
and don't tell me oh they're just
commuting it's a whole gang of them with
their little spandex outfits and
everything they're not all commuting to
work they're just doing it for fun they
said let's go let's get together go for
a bicycle ride in the middle of the
street
right at the time you know Prime
commuting time people are coming home
from work the middle of the road back
Country Roads you're holding everybody
up and endangering their safety
for the sake of your Recreation
sociopaths I don't know how we allow
this I don't know how we allow it this
should be illegal they should there
should be a a Paddy Wagon showing up
and just cuffing all these people and
throwing them into and taking them to
jail that's what should happen
how are you not don't
I wasn't going to get into it is my last
point
how do you not feel uncomfortable at
least like if I was on a bicycle in the
middle of the street
and there was a whole line of cars
behind me I would feel uncomfortable
knowing that I'm inconveniencing all
these people just because I want to have
fun it would make me very uncomfortable
I would feel bad about that
I would be able to feel their glare
right like on the back of my neck I
would just know they're glaring at me
and I would be forced to just move to
the side of the road because I don't
like inconveniencing people if I can
help it
for these cyclists are just no
self-awareness or either that or they
want
to cause these problems
it's these Insidious villains
anyway all right so speaking of
Insidious villains yesterday Lindsey
Graham
um normally a squish extraordinaire made
a surprise announcement he was
introducing a bill in the Senate
to ban abortion federally across the
country at 15 weeks so here he is uh
making the announcement yesterday
so here's what I think we will be doing
about The Unborn we will introduce
legislation I along with a lot of my
colleagues to basically get America in a
position at the federal level I think is
fairly consistent with the rest of the
world can we
we have charts
it shows you how serious we are
all right
15 weeks the babies at the 15-week
period what does that mean well it means
if you're going to operate on the baby
which happens to save the child's life
to provide a medical treatment the
standard practice in medicine is to
provide anesthesia now why would you do
that you provide anesthesia because the
science tells us that the 15-week period
the nerve endings of the baby are pretty
well developed in the pal and the child
feels pain
so here's our point that if you have to
provide anesthesia to keep the baby from
feeling pain to help save its life
should we as a nation be aborting babies
that can feel excruciating pain from an
abortion
uh no we should not absolutely we should
not uh he he's he's right about
everything he's saying there children
can feel pain they're human beings
um killing them is a horrific crime
it is it is quite perverse to say the
least that if you operate on an unborn
child which is correct that that is also
something that happens quite frequently
that operations on on human beings in
the womb and they use anesthesia but uh
through the process of abortion you know
it's there's obviously no anesthesia
because there's no recognition that this
human being is a human being so if we're
going to operate
on the child then we recognize the child
as a human in abortion we pretend that
the child isn't it doesn't make any
sense whatsoever
all of that is true
and yet I
disagree
with what Lindsey Graham is doing here I
am against it I'm against this bill
right now at this point in time and I'll
explain why
now first of all I don't need to go over
my pro-life credentials here I'm as
pro-life as they come you know that I'm
radically pro-life I am pro-life from
conception I've been fighting against
the abortion industry my whole public
career and before that so that's
something that you all know Banning
abortion at 15 weeks definitely I would
ban abortion from conception that's how
I want to ban it I want a uh my you know
I I think our ultimate goal the thing we
really want is a constitutional
amendment a personhood Amendment
which we shouldn't need because the
Constitution already protects uh you
know guarantees the rights of of all
human beings which which obviously
includes those in the womb but we sh we
do need it and that's what I would want
to see I'm in favor of a federal ban
also I am in favor of a federal ban I'm
not one of these conservatives who says
that this is well it's a state's issue
this is a state's rights issue lots of
conservatives say that I don't say that
that's not what I think
I don't think states have the right to
legalize the murder of babies I believe
in state rights but obviously states
rights is not an absolute they don't
have the right to legalize anything they
want
um
and I don't think they have the right
they don't have the moral right they
shouldn't have the legal right to to to
uh to permit the murder of
babies I I don't think that the genocide
of an entire category of people is
something that falls within the purview
of states rights
but I'm against the bill why well
because it's very simple
and let's establish something from the
outset
there's zero debate about this part of
it the legislation that he's introducing
will not become law the bill will not
become law it is literally impossible
that the bill that Lindsey Graham is
introducing will become law impossible
okay Congress and the White House are
controlled by the Democrats and they are
not going to pass a federal abortion ban
they won't even let it come up for a
vote it's not going to happen never
impossible you'd have better luck
jumping off of a 100-story business
building and using like a napkin as a
parachute it's just it's it's not going
to happen
um and this isn't even one of those well
it's worth a try no you never know but
no this is not even a try that's like
that's like putting a I don't know
putting a rock in a microwave and and
saying well maybe an elephant will pop
out it's worth a try
no that is that is not within the realm
of possible outcomes it just isn't
so why introduce the bill well it's a
political play that's all it is that's
all it can be it's its only function so
that's the only way that we should be
judging this is as a political play
because that is all it can be now I have
no problem in theory
with proposing doomed legislation as a
political strategy
when you're in the minority you're the
minority party you don't control
Congress you don't control the White
House you can't actually pass anything
does that mean you shouldn't propose
anything no I'm I think it could be a
good strategy sometimes to propose bills
that you know will not pass
in theory
but it has to be a good political
strategy because that's all it is is a
political strategy so is this a good
political strategy what is the strategy
in proposing this legislation right now
before the midterms
all it does is give the Democrats
exactly what they want they want to talk
about a federal abortion ban they want
to distract from the economy from crime
from the transiting of kids from the
education system from The Grooming that
they're doing all of that they don't
want to talk about any of that they want
to talk about a federal abortion ban
it's very clear that they want to talk
about that
and so Graham is giving them exactly
what they want this is exactly what they
want to talk about
um
now
it only makes sense to do something like
this
if a federal abortion ban at 15 weeks is
massively enormously popular because
then if it's massively enormously
popular for it to have a federal
abortion ban at 50 weeks then you can
incentivize voters to vote for you with
with the promise that you'll pass the
law if you're voted in even though like
even if the Republicans there was a
landslide there's a red wave at the
midterms they still can't pass any laws
because it'd be vetoed by the White
House but still as an incentive it makes
sense if this if you're proposing a
really popular piece of legislation it
also changes the conversation
to focus on this popular piece of
legislation
but is a federal 15-week abortion ban
that popular
no I mean not according to any poll not
by any metric it should be popular but
it isn't it should be popular but it
isn't
there are varying claims about how
unpopular it is but the fact is that
it's not nearly here's what we could say
at a minimum
it is not nearly popular enough
to justify this strategy
if you're going to put up legislation
like this right before the midterms then
it has to be an absolute home run
that's going to be like you're going to
get 60 70 approval from the voters for
just just then it makes sense to do
um but that's not the case with with a
federal abortion ban
I mean at best this is like it's a split
down the middle you know type of thing
which is a sort of issue that you that's
the kind of thing that you do it's the
sort of thing you work on it's the sort
of thing you push after the election not
before it
this is not the conversation the
Republicans should be having going into
the midterms it helps Democrats not
Republicans if you want to pass pro-life
legislation you need a pro-life
government and this makes that less
likely to happen you have decreased the
possibility of actually passing a bill
like this by proposing it a few weeks
before the midterms at a time when the
Democrats are desperate to change the
topic and to focus on something like
this that's why the Dems were they were
they were they were practically crying
tears of joy when Graham announced this
they were ecstatic
all of them were in front of microphones
and cameras and they had their
fundraising pitches ready to go within
19 seconds
they were so excited about this
here's uh Chuck Chuck shoes Republicans
are fixated on their extremist agenda
like a National Abortion ban Democrats
are focused on creating jobs lowering
costs and bringing the country together
now that's that's total nonsense of
course they're focused on creating jobs
and bringing the country together that's
not it's not exhaust at all what they're
focused on but that's that's the that is
exactly the talking point they wanted uh
the Republicans are focused on this and
this is what we're this is what we're
doing uh Katie Porter in California had
an ad ready to go within like 30 minutes
here here's that
the Supreme Court has taken away our
right to choose giving politicians power
to control women's most personal health
decisions in Washington they're planning
a nationwide ban on abortion no
exceptions not for rape or incest the
word extreme gets tossed around a lot
but making it illegal to have an
abortion no exceptions truly is Extreme
I'm Katie Porter I'll fight any attempt
at a nationwide abortion ban
okay now I am a I'd be the first to say
that we don't decide what we're going to
do as conservatives based on what the
left will say about it you know we can't
refrain from doing the right thing
because the left will be mad about it
that obviously is how I feel
but again given that this is just a
political play and that's all it can be
you have to think is it is it smart
politically to give the Democrats
exactly the conversation that they want
right now
not to mention
um as uh Karen Jean pair pointed out
right correctly when she was talking
about this at the White House Press
Conference she quoted Lindsey Graham
from a month ago on TV saying that he
thinks abortion is a state's issue and
shouldn't be decided by the federal
government he did say that a month ago
I don't even agree with that I think
that she again I think the federal
government does have a role but that's
what he said and now he's the one who's
coming out with this
he's never been a big pro-life advocate
in the first place like Lindsey Graham
when does he ever show that he gives a
damn about the pro-life cause
in the past when Republicans have
controlled the government Lindsey Graham
wasn't leading the charge to pass
pro-life legislation
and there are things that could be done
even when Roe v Wade was still active
so when they actually have the ability
to do something he doesn't want to do
anything and when the bill can't pass
that's when he's behind it
it you know it's it's almost like he
wants Republicans to lose
that's the conspiracy theory that I
would actually uh
subscribe to here he wants Republicans
to lose this is a uh this is sabotage
it's the only way to explain it
given who it's coming from especially
it's one thing that this is coming from
someone in Congress who's just been
deeply pro-life a pro-life activist for
years and this has been their number one
issue and so that you know and this is
all they talk is this is one of their
Central things that they talk about all
the time and um and you know this is
they're just so excited about it that
they maybe put the cart before the horse
a little bit and came out and and
proposed this before right before the
midterms that would be one thing now I'd
still say it's a bad political strategy
but then at least I could believe that
it's sincere in this case I don't even
believe that it's sincere
this to me seems like sabotage
because there are Republicans who want
to be the minority party they want to be
the opposition they want to be in the
position of of proposing laws that they
know cannot pass
you know what if you want to pass a bill
or rather not passable because you can't
pass it if you want to propose a bill
right before the midterms
with the intention of
changing the conversation or focusing
conversation on something that that's
that's politically good for you to be
talking about
and with the intention also of making
Democrats seem extreme by their
opposition to it here's the bill that
you should be proposing okay so what all
the Republicans in the Senate should be
getting together Mitch McConnell and and
uh
Lindsey Graham and all them should be
coming out holding the press conference
saying that they are proposing a federal
ban
on child castration
and on cosmetic double mastectomies for
minor girls that's what they should be
doing
not going to pass no way it's going to
pass
but politically that's a winner
because now you're putting the Democrats
in the position right before the
midterms of having to defend castrating
and butchering kids
now that is a winning political strategy
and and we can guarantee the vast
majority of this country if they are
made aware this is even happening and
many people don't know that it's
happening but if they're made aware of
it of course they're going to be against
it
that's what you do if you want to win
of course problem with the Republicans
is they don't often want to win
all right um
let's move to so that was that was uh
someone ostensibly pretending to be
pro-life who doesn't want to win here's
someone who does like to win on the
pro-life side uh Lila Rose of live
action appeared on Dr Phil
to talk about the abortion issue and I
want to play a little bit of this clip
because I thought it was pretty
compelling
the predicate of your positions that
life begins at fertilization that
science is very clear about that and you
have to know science isn't there's no
consensus among the scientific community
if you're an in vitro specialist you're
looking to create a single cell embryo
and then you know you have a new human
life
so it is a scientific fact
well actually it's not when do you when
do you say human life begins then
there's well it doesn't matter what I
think I I don't care what I think what
I'm saying is the scientific Community
does not have a consensus about when
life begins
it's simply inaccurate that's not true
you can go to the body angle cell embryo
is a unique new human life
you can go to the body of scientific
literature and you can find
neuroscientists who say that it begins
when there is a detectable brainwave an
abortion if it's not a human life why do
you have to kill it I haven't spoken
over you and you keep speaking over me
and I assume that's because you don't
want me to finish
my thought which is
if anyone here wants to fact check me
instead of speak over me you can go to
the scientific literature and query
what the definition is of the beginning
of Life
okay so things got uh contentious there
I will say I I do give credit to Dr Phil
um even though we clearly are seem to be
on opposite sides of the of the abortion
issue
I give credit to him for this reason and
that is that he
doesn't just talk about these kinds of
issues on his show but he actually
brings this is the part that is unique
he brings people on from the
conservative side who are able and
articulate Defenders of the position
you know and and he brings them on to
defend the position rather than taking
the CNN approach or the MSNBC approach
and finding some brainless
uh Patsy whose only role is to get is
all who's only you know there just to
get steamrolled
the controlled opposition you know
strategy
so he doesn't do that
um he was talking about critical race
Theory back in the summer he brought on
James Lindsay to talk about it talk
about gender Theory brought me on to
talk about it uh wants to discuss the
pro-life issue
brings on Lila Rose
you know as a pro-lifer myself if
someone
if Dr Phil had come to me and said who
do you think is the best person to to
bring on my show to talk about abortion
I would have recommended her she'd be
the one I would have recommended
um so I do appreciate that
of course Lila Rose is correct though in
this discussion
um life does begin a conception
it's not really up for debate it's the
only logical point
for life to begin
and the reason is this now we could talk
about the you know what the scientists
say and everything and the and I always
you know always on the on the
pro-abortion side they want to find
Wells you know the consensus scientific
consensus says this or that there are
certainly no scientific consensus that
life does not begin to conception
most scientists will tell you that it
does because there's no way around it
and then you might have other scientists
that say well you know we don't really
know
but even outside of that it's just it's
a it's a matter of logic
the way that we know that life begins
because of conception is that at
conception there is
something right there's a there's a
physical entity which exists
we agree we can agree on that point
uh well any physical entity which exists
must exist in a state some kind of state
and they're really only three options
every physical entity
is alive or dead or inanimate so you can
look around the room that you're
currently sitting in look anywhere look
under a microscope and all you will see
anywhere are things that are living
things that are dead and things which
are inanimate matter
well the physical entity at conception
must be one of these
right so if you're saying it's not alive
then it has to be something else and
what is it well we know it's not dead
we know that
we know it's not inanimate matter
because it's organic matter it's growing
it's developing it's it's becoming it
has DNA it has a genetic code
it is in no way like a like a a chair or
a rock
or anything else that is that is uh that
is inanimate
so
what's left well it's it's living it's
it's a living physical entity
there's no real way around that
so if you're on the pro-abortion side
what you really believe now you might
you might you know I don't know if it's
really living or not no it is it's just
there's no way it is it certainly is
um but what you're actually saying is
that sometimes it is okay to destroy in
this innocent helpless human life
that is your whether you're whether
you'll say it out loud or not that is
actually your position
but there's a reason why you don't want
to say it out loud uh and that is that
it's a horrifying position
all right the Emmys were on Sunday
um
I didn't know that this was happening of
course until I saw the outrage on
Twitter there's always there always has
to be some sort of awards outrage that
comes out of these things and this time
sometimes the outrage is sort of fun to
talk about the Will Smith thing I mean
that was a classic right that was that
was act that was actually an enjoyable
awards show related outrage that was
enjoyable to talk about and entertaining
um the one from the Emmys this is a
little disappointing it doesn't quite
live up to the hype so Jimmy Kimmel did
a bit
I don't know all the background on this
I don't care the bit I guess is that he
he was up presenting the award for some
category and uh he pretended to pass out
for some reason on the stage
and then they announced the winner and
it was an actress who was black
and Kimmel kept lying there
still pretending to be passed out even
as she came up to give her acceptance
speech Let's uh let's watch a little bit
of that moment
Quinter Brunson Elementary
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Jimmy
okay hold my phone
um
my goodness
okay and then she uh could she just
gives her acceptance speech with the guy
lying there it is it's awkward
and weird
uh and that's really all that could be
said about it but but but
as always social media and the news
media they're not satisfied to just say
that because there's there are racial
Dynamics here you know it's Jimmy
Kimmel's a white guy this actress is a
black woman
and so now they're making it racial and
so all these headlines saying that it
was racist it was racist for Jimmy
Kimmel to to steal the woman's shine
like that you know as all these posts on
social media white men are always doing
this damn white men yeah because there's
something white men always do white men
are constantly lying on award show
stages while people are trying to give
uh give their acceptance speeches it's
just it's a thing we always do it's part
of our culture
now
um
this just shows again the problem with
racializing everything
because you it's guaranteed that you're
going to miss the point
and also you end up distracting from
valid criticisms in this case this is
like a small example of it but there's a
very valid criticism you could make of
Jimmy Kimmel he's he's an ass I mean
Jimmy Kimmel is a jerk he's a bad person
and he's arrogant and self-centered and
yeah he wanted to make this moment about
him I'd be annoyed too if I if I'm up
there giving my acceptance speech when I
win an Emmy and there's just some jerk
laying on the ground you know because he
thought of this bad comedy bit and he's
he's doing it in the middle of my I'd be
annoyed by that
and you know just like kick them in the
ribs or something and make them move
but it's not racial like the idea that
he did it because she's a black woman
he said to himself oh this is a black
woman I gotta yeah
I gotta do what I can to intrude here
is absurd
although it is kind of uh it is kind of
funny that
Jimmy Kimmel
to this point you know with the racial
outrage for great Brigade out there
searching for racism wherever they can
find it often Landing in places where
the racism ends up being imaginary and
invisible you know they're over at BYU
searching for an invisible racist who
silently shouted the n-word meanwhile
Jimmy Kimmel has been a late night
Network TV host for years now and there
are tons of videos of him out there in
blackface this is something this guy did
all the time back in the in the 90s
he was constantly a blackface
and somehow he has escaped criticism for
that
so it'd be kind of funny if this is what
brings him down like this is the racial
controversy that brings him down where
he wasn't even actually being racist
it's a little bit of the you know the
O.J Simpson thing where they couldn't
get him for murder so instead they get
him for stealing his own merchandise
back or whatever it was so basically
it's a kind of a same thing here they
didn't get Jimmy Kimmel for the black
face so they're gonna get him for this
instead
um all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I will tell you a little bit of good
news from my own life is that my wife
has finally come around to the fact that
we need to buy a van and the SUVs aren't
going to cut it I mean I told you when
we when we first
found out we were having twins she you
know has been anti-van our entire
marriage and she still had this idea
that even with six kids we wouldn't have
to get a van now she's realizing that um
that there's no way around it we got to
get the van the van is inevitable
except now she's looking up vans that
are like 95 000 or whatever meanwhile I
go on Craigslist and I find vans for
sale for under eight grand I mean you
could find I found I found a van for 400
on Craigslist and I'm sure I'm sending
her all these links
Astro Vans now those are the real deal
they don't make them anymore you can
only find them on Craigslist you can
only find them used but my family had an
Astro van growing up our uh our uh our
rear passenger door was falling off and
was actually duct taped on that's true
and I got about six miles to the gallon
the engine sounded like a like a polar
bear drowning or something it was a
great vehicle it was great there were
vomit stains on the third row seat
because I had a car sickness problem and
I didn't have a uh my relief band back
then it's just a great vehicle
there were holes rusted on the side
panel it's like big holes
my brother fell through one of them on
the highway we never saw him again it
was a great fantastic a classic
and I'm looking forward to having
something like that again all right Max
Winter says a black actor playing The
Little Mermaid really is a case of white
Erasure all forms of art including fairy
tales are meant to be reflections of the
author's experiences and observations
Hans Christian Anderson probably based a
Little Mermaid based on experiences he
went through in his home country of
Denmark so it makes sense that most of
his characters would be white since
that's the world and the people he was
surrounded by
yeah I'm given
the way that we deal with these sorts of
issues I'm I'm sympathetic to that now I
would be fine like we talked about
yesterday we don't have to rehash the
entire thing but
if we all agreed
that race in in films and TV shows
especially fictional stories don't
matter
and we're going to take a kind of
colorblind casting approach and uh you
know it just it doesn't matter as long
as the actor is good if we could all
agree on that then I'd be on board and
as I said that's basically what it was
for many years what it was back in the
90s
but what I cannot
abide by
is the double standard thing where we
say well race the race the casting uh
the race of in casting matters only for
certain races and not for others that
that no no we're not doing that
also by the way with the little mermaid
can we also just mention that just from
from a scientific perspective
okay it doesn't make a lot of sense to
have someone with darker skin who lives
deep in the ocean I mean if anything I
mean not only should The Little Mermaid
be pale she should actually be
translucent if you look at deep sea
creatures they're like translucent they
have no kind of pigmentation whatsoever
and they're just like these horrifying
they look like skeletons floating around
in the ocean that's what the Little
Mermaid should look like she should be
totally pale or and skeletal where you
can see her skull through her face
and that would actually be a version of
Little Mermaid that I would watch
um
let's see Dionysus voice says Matt I
really have to express my outrage
disgust and offense at your comparison
withsters and octopi
unlike walksters octopi have been known
to demonstrate a significant amount of
intelligence
well you pretend to be some sort of
expert but actually octopi this is uh
this is some sort this is like a
misnomer that the plural of octopuses is
octopi that's actually not true it is
octopuses just
and because you lacked that knowledge
about octopuses you're Ben from the show
um
and finally Brandon Kelly says I was
looking at a book of African fairy tales
and I want to buy it because these
stories are not as well known as the
European ones but what makes it sad is
that Hollywood refuses to adapt these
stories because they rather have a
Latina Rapunzel or a black Cinderella
than anything yeah and that's another
very good point that other people
um brought up as we were talking about
this and that is if if we're making the
decision if we're saying if Hollywood is
saying okay we need to have more black
people who are leads in these kinds of
stores we need to have more children's
stories with black leads we need to have
fairy tales with uh black leads just
like they say we need more uh female
action heroes like
well then why not come make new stories
rather than taking the old stories and
flipping them around
and say oh well now we have we're going
to take this action franchise and now we
have the girl version of it and we're
going to take this fairy tale we're
gonna make the Black version of it
rather than doing that how about just
tell a new story
then you know what everybody wins that's
a win for everybody you get the
representation that you want and we also
get new stories we get rather than
recycling the same damn thing over and
over again
okay they're gonna make another
Pinocchio in three years and it's gonna
be Tran you know like trans uh a trans
Asian pansexual Pinocchio rather than
that let's just look at we've told that
story we have a million iterations of
Pinocchio how about just tell a new
story
crazy idea
well big announcement this week maybe
you've heard Candace Owens is back from
maternity leave with a Vengeance her
brand new show Candace Owens is
available now on daily wire plus and
takes on the big topics of the day
uncovers lies and exposes the hypocrisy
in news and politics and you know what's
going to be done in typical kind of
style fearless and Resolute this is
everything you love about Canada's only
now
she is streaming five days a week you'll
not want to miss her explosive first
episode which premiered this week trust
me when I say this is huge watch Candace
owens's show now on daily wire Plus or
listen on Apple podcast Spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so last week we looked at a couple of
recent attempts to finally solve the
what is a woman riddle as you may
remember they both failed in spectacular
fashion their answers didn't even make
it past square one they blew up on the
launch pad and killed everybody on board
metaphorically but at least they tried
because we've finally forced the left to
confront this question they realized
they cannot evade it any longer they
have to confront it and so all of the
best Minds in the gender ideology world
have set to work this is like a the
Manhattan Project of green-haired gender
studies Majors they're all on the
problem now they've been brainstorming
Around the Clock an All-Star team of the
smartest and most insightful gender
activists in the world all with
comparatively impressive IQs compared to
the rest of them some reaching even into
the high double digits and they've been
digging into this problem deliberating
searching desperately for a solution
and yet so far
a woman is anyone who identifies as a
woman is the best that any of them have
been able to do
it's as though the Manhattan Project
spent years on research and development
and rather than inventing the nuclear
bomb they came up with like a
firecracker although at least a
firecracker is an actual thing it exists
it makes sense
a woman is anyone who identifies as a
woman is nothing it's not a definition
it's not anything it's circular it's
incoherent and yet again it is the best
that they have been able to do
until now
here to meet the challenge or to Die
Trying is a writer called Paul John
poles Paul is a a self-identified
feminine trans man which I guess is a
female
who identifies as a male
and sees herself as feminine
that presents its own bundle of chords
to untangle but there's not time for
that today it does mean though that the
writer is coming at this question from a
from a pretty unique perspective because
usually the gender ideologues who try to
tackle the woman question are males who
wish to find a definition of woman that
will include them but in this case
interestingly enough we have a female
who wishes to find a definition of woman
that does not include her
how will she do it
well PJP Begins by acknowledging a few
points that the gender ideologues
usually prefer to ignore she points out
that gender cannot rest on stereotypes
and social constructs as her side
usually has it because that effectively
excludes a lot of people from Womanhood
that she doesn't want to exclude it also
includes her but she doesn't want to be
included
next the writer recognizes that a woman
is anyone who identifies as a woman is
circular and therefore logically invalid
she does acknowledge that she also
points to another problem that I hadn't
even thought about
with the uh you know a woman who's
anyone identifies as a woman definition
she says that that hinging the
definition of woman on
self-identification
is a problem for her side because it
excludes people who don't yet
consciously identify as women but may at
some point in the future you know the
trans Community creepily refers to
people who they think might be trans or
can be turned trans as eggs that's what
they call them eggs right eggs that need
to be hatched
and uh they may sort of uh home in on a
boy who they think could be made into a
girl a process that we used to call
grooming before every social media site
banned the term but the point is that
they want to be able to say
that the boy is already a girl and has
always been a girl
yet hasn't realized it
that's what they want to say
so when uh when when the boy is nine
years old and first says I'm a girl
uh no it's the the trans side they don't
say that he just became a girl then they
said oh he was always a girl even before
that
he just came to realize it now
well see that doesn't work if the very
definition of Womanhood or girlhood
relies on conscious self-identification
that's another problem
so what can be done about this here's
the writer's solution
I'm going to read now
quote
this finally brings us to our definition
a woman is an adult human whose
subconscious sex is female
the beauty of it is that it doesn't
include trans men or CIS men their
subconscious sex is male and it includes
both CIS women and trans women their
subconscious sex is female and it also
doesn't invalidate gender non-conforming
trans and CIS people and the best thing
about it is that the person who is best
qualified to know whether or not you are
a woman is still you which means that we
can still keep our beloved ethical
guideline of respecting people's
self-identification except that now the
word woman actually means something
well no it doesn't in fact it's never
meant less if that's the definition now
I can appreciate that you've made a
valiant effort to avoid a circular
definition but unfortunately your
efforts have driven you even farther off
The Logical path and deep into the woods
where it's dark and confusing and no
light penetrates through the canopy
um it's even worse now so let's review
all the problems with this definition
number one
uh your your subconscious by definition
is the part of your mind that you don't
have access to you are unaware of it
actually the subconscious or unconscious
mind is a psychoanalytical theory
invented by Freud and there are all
kinds of logical and scientific problems
with it it also has given risen to all
manner of psychiatric fads and panics
such as the infamous repressed memory
hysteria back in the 90s with a whole
bunch of women in therapy all realized
all of a sudden that they had been
abused as children and then a whole
bunch of people got arrested based on
that and it turned out that they were
like imagining it
um for that matter the concept of
transgenderism wouldn't exist either
without these Freudian concepts of you
know the unconscious mind and so forth
so there are problems is what I'm saying
with the whole idea of the subconscious
at least as it has traditionally been
understood
but that takes us off on a tangent about
how the entire field of psychoanalysis
is built on nonsense Fabrications and
wild theories invented by a bunch of
weirdos 100 years ago we're going to
leave that to the side and stay focused
the point is that the term subconscious
means I mean this is what it means the
part of your mind you aren't aware of
so if someone is subconsciously female
they wouldn't know that they're female
if you know that you're female then you
are consciously female not
subconsciously but of course saying a
woman is anyone who is consciously
female is just another way of saying
that a woman is anyone who identifies as
a woman you're trying to avoid the
endless logical Loop which is why you've
introduced the subconscious into the
equation but you can't really do that
the subconscious cannot save you in fact
its entrance into the conversation
creates far more problems for you than
it solves
also your subconscious cannot have a sex
your Consciousness also does not have a
sex in and of itself
by definition sex is a physical category
having to do with reproductive organs
and chromosomes and DNA
you you are here positing a scenario
where a person with a physical sex of
male
could have a mind even an unconscious
mind
with the physical sex of female
so you have turned the Mind into its own
physical entity literally contained
inside the physical body and which has
its own DNA
this is what you're doing not to the
mind not to the brain but to the mind
essentially you're Imagining the human
body as some sort of fleshy shell with a
whole other person inside it steering it
around that makes for a good plot point
in a science fiction film but it's not
how things work in reality
in reality you can cut a person open and
inspect every part of them including
their brain external and internal and
all you will find are physical body
parts and every physical body part has
physical DNA which will attest to the
physical sex of that person
and that's why your definition doesn't
work and makes no sense
and in the end is even less coherent
than the definition that you were trying
to avoid giving
that's really the problem isn't it
though
what you're trying to avoid that's the
issue
see it's it's it's very clear
has never been more clear
that the gender ideologues really what
they actually want to talk about is the
human soul
every day they move closer to the
precipice inching toward it step by step
they talk about self-identity and inner
awareness and gender identity and
subconscious sex now but what they mean
what they want to say
is that humans have a soul
and sometimes the soul doesn't match
with the body
they stop themselves from saying that
because they don't want to admit that
gender ideology is through and through a
religion it's a religious spiritual
claim it's a matter of faith
this is the secret they're trying to
keep hidden but they're coming closer
and closer to dropping the scientific
mask and admitting the truth that this
is this is religious this is what they
this is a religious claim they believe
in the soul and when they say that a man
is really a woman
they mean that he is spiritually a woman
that his soul is that of a woman
that's what they mean
of course understood that way it still
is nonsense doesn't make any sense at
all you cannot talk about souls without
talking about God and he's the one who
makes the souls and the body
and it's absurd obviously to claim that
God would make some sort of mistake on
the spiritual assembly line and
accidentally plop a female Soul into a
male body
that doesn't make any sense
I mean what sort of what sort of vision
of God are you now postulating
some sort of bumbling uh fool up there
in heaven that's just like you know
throwing different souls in a
mismatching bodies there's no idea
what's going on
besides this concept of souls is built
on a this concept the concept that the
gender ideologues have is built on this
weird kind of dualism where the soul is
seen as once again an entity located
inside the body and steering it along
like like the body is some sort of
two-legged SUV but in reality our souls
and bodies exist in harmony with each
other it's not that we are bodies and we
have souls or that we are souls and have
bodies we are souls and we are bodies
we cannot be one thing spiritually and
the opposite thing physically
that that's a contradiction
you might as well say that you have the
body of a human and the soul of a
raccoon or an oak tree it just doesn't
make any sense
so retreating into the spiritual realm
will not actually save gender Theory it
actually makes it even more absurd than
it was when it was judged purely on a
scientific basis but at least
if we are talking about it spiritually
at least then the conversation is being
had in an honest way at least the gender
ideologues would finally be saying what
they actually mean
and that would be progress
though again it will not save them
or our friend Paul John Pauls from being
today canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move into the members
block hope to see you there if not
talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]